Immediately I
went to a day school or prep school in
Jeddah,
the only one to an international modern
standard in the kingdom at the time.
And he was,
uh,
essentially recruited into an Islamic
group by a charismatic Syrian Gym
teacher at his prep school who mentored
him and taught him and essentially
indoctrinated him into the Muslim
Brotherhood.
And that was the beginning of a series
of relationships with mentors,
essentially professional mentors that
seemed also to have a sort of personal
role in his life of dilemmas.
Uh,
who was a collaborator and,
and Co founder of,
of,
um,
the precursor organization to al Qaeda
during the anti-soviet war.
Ayman Elza Walker,
relater,
the Egyptian who co founded,
um,
al Qaeda with him though,
is while he was his deputy,
he was also in a,
in a sort of biographical sense,
also a mentor and a and a,
uh,
a kind of a patron of Osama.
The overall narrative is,
um,
you know,
maybe not too surprising,
but worth just sketching,
which is he's a shy,
a privileged,
wealthy young man who is recruited into
International Islamic radicalism and his
mentor and doted on primarily at first
because of his money and his older,
more ambitious mentors want access to
what he has,
not only his own deep pockets,
but also the fundraising world that he
can open up in Saudi Arabia,
but gradually as he,
as he ages and as he matures,
he either overthrows his mentors,
are slowly separates from them and all
and develops his own ambition and his
own very full egotistical sense of his
own capabilities.
And I don't think in the end he is a
prisoner of his mentors.
I think in instead he,
he sort of grows beyond them.
By and large,
evens watery,
always has often been a creature of
media and has yearned to be heard.
And this particularly as he came into
his own and decided that he had a role
to play in this narrative that he
imagined he had been called into by God
and,
and where he was drawn.
Also for reasons of his own ambition,
he he loved to.
He had an intuition about a brand
building and about media that was really
one of his core talents and one of his
core insights and a source of much of
his innovation and achievement and after
nine slash 11,
he had to repress some of those
instincts because it was too risky to go
on television as often as he might like.
You can see him when he comes forward.
Even after periods of silence,
he comes forward with a video where he
comes forward with an audio tape and if
you read through the text of everything
he's been saying since nine slash 11
when he does surface to talk or you look
at those videotapes,
you have the impression of someone who's
in hiding but has access to a lot of
media.
He's reading.
He's clearly reading books.
He's clearly as access to the news,
whether it's on the internet or on
satellite television and he's and you
all sometimes you always had the sense
that he's like watching President Bush
on television,
make a speech,
and he just gets.
He gets.
He,
I gotta I gotTa talk,
I gotta say something,
bring my media guy,
and then he goes and he makes a speech
and he's almost talking back to the,
to the global media.
So I do think is there is clearly an
impulse that he has,
um,
uh,
to be heard.
That's how he's always conceived as role
as a vanguard,
someone who stimulates a and encourages
others not as someone who needs to
control a political organization or be
the boss,
but someone who inspires you.
It sort of confirms
the little bits of information that were
available about his family's
circumstances.
In this period of exile,
the Sama has had at least four or five
wives.
The wives that are known are,
have all returned to their home
countries.
I believe almost all of his daughters,
if not all of his daughters,
have also returned home.
He has perhaps a dozen or more sons and
of those,
some have returned home and some were
believed like Hamza to be an exile with
him if perhaps living with him,
perhaps living near him.
There was an exchange between Osama and
his son,
Hamza on the,
on Jihadi websites in late 2001 where a
Sama essentially wrote a letter to Hamza
in the form of a last will and
testament.
And so Hamza,
along with a couple of other sons,
have clearly been with them.
They've appeared in videos before as
young jihadi is even at ages nine and 10
by now,
Hamza,
I guess I don't know what the video
shows today,
buddy.
I would guess he's about 16 or 17.
Um,
and uh,
so he would have been one of the three
or four that you would have guessed was
roughly wherever Osama's hiding along
the Pak Afghan frontier that Hamza is
out there too,
probably a lot.
And then Mohammed and a couple others
are out there as well.
I think he's a long time
Afghan,
Pakistan border.
Um,
and you know,
sometimes to try to play a,
sort of,
have this parlor game you could play
with people who watch al Qaeda or the
pay attention to search for bin Ladin.
Suppose someone walks into the room
right now and says,
oh,
som has been captured,
or someone just hit them with a
Predator,
a gay,
you say,
okay,
interesting.
Don't tell me where.
Put a map up on the wall,
take a pin,
put the pin in the map and you know,
10 people closest to the whole winds,
you know,
where,
who can come closest to where he
actually was.
And so where would you put your pin?
And I would probably put it
in northwest zero.
Stand around Mirin shot along the
border.
There's a area they're controlled by the
[inaudible] clan that he has long roots
in.
There are some risks to him if he stays
in that area.
And so maybe it's a little too busy and
a little too trafficked.
An alternative place where,
uh,
some other smart people who know them in
intelligence,
they tend to put their pins just a
little bit north of that in Bodger,
but it's basically a general area,
um,
around the,
the federally administrated tribal
areas.
Probably more north than south would be
my best stuff
very
much
at a couple of levels.
It samas ideology is not very fully
formed.
I don't think his analysis or his
ideology or his political program are by
any means.
His strengths is he has talents,
but ultimately,
um,
this sense of ideology and,
and strategy is,
is not one of them.
And,
and,
and ultimately I think al Qaeda will be
defeated by the self limiting nature of
his ideology.
However,
to the extent that he has ideology,
it has sort of two levels.
One is a political sort of terra firma
here and now set of grievances in which
he's trying to give voice to a,
an eclectic array of legitimate
grievances in the Islamic world.
And on the other hand,
he has a millenarian view of himself as
leading a preordained war called by God
that will end at the end of time and at
both levels the metaphor of a war.
And the fact of war are central to his
claim on his followers.
So,
uh,
when the Bush administration after nine
slash 11 announces a war against him and
frames a global war in which he is the
adversary,
it provides exactly the narrative that
he's been.
It reinforces and elevates and
accentuates the narrative that he's been
developing and certainly he would
embrace and has embraced the sort of
equivalency that the war narrative
provides between himself and say George
W dot Bush on the one hand,
the president of the hyper power of the
post early post Cold War period.
And on the other hand,
Osama bin Ladin leading the righteous
forces of Islam against the oppression,
uh,
carried out by that hyper power.
And so the Bush administration sort of
fairly quickly realized,
especially after they turned their
attention from pursuing him and toward
invading Iraq,
that maybe it wasn't a good idea to call
attention to his.
So they,
they,
they've gone through this kind of
bipolar or sort of swings in their,
in their attitude towards the psalm as
an adversary trying to not elevate and
by not talking about him,
uh,
but then that only emphasizes the
impunity that he seems to enjoy it.
It's,
it's an organization with a particular
leader and deputy leader and a bunch of
committees and a headquarters sort of.
And some,
you know,
it is a continuous organization that was
founded at meetings in 1988,
has had the same bureaucracy and the
same leader and deputy leader for 20
years.
So there is an organization,
it's called Al Qaeda,
has a boss and it has committees that do
finance and media and military.
It's more than that though.
It's also a movement that inspires
followers who are disconnected from
leaders.
It's also a network of likeminded
organizations and it's also a brand that
attempts to attract other organizations
and adherence,
whether in groups or as individuals.
So Al Qaeda is I think properly
understood a synthesis of these
characteristics today.
Al Qaeda,
the organization is resilient militarily
in the sense that they continue to be
able to run medium sized attacks into
Europe.
They are struggling politically.
I think they are strategically,
uh,
in,
in a corner that they're not likely to
get out of.
I'm very easily.
But the organization a is still a factor
in the security threats faced by not
only the United States but also Britain
and Germany and Denmark.
I tend to be the,
I've been my
obvious sort of thoughts previewed the,
the idea that,
yeah,
I think they're both right.
I mean,
I,
I do.
Here's a concrete example and,
and I think it,
it proves the case that they're both
right.
Um,
the July seventh subway bombings in
London,
um,
I think you can add the evidence is
pretty well now established that that
attack was supported by al Qaeda
headquarters in Pakistan and was
supported by the travel that some of the
participants in the plot undertook to
meet al Qaeda operatives in Waziristan.
And on the other hand,
the plot originated spontaneously in the
disaffected lives,
have some Pakistani originated British
citizens in Leeds.
So on the one hand you could say that
attack would never have occurred without
the independent grassroots individually
alienation of the Pakistan Navy,
Britain in leads.
On the other hand,
it would not have occurred also without
the resilient al Qaeda organization.
You can,
it's like an extra drawing.
You can emphasize one side of that
equation or the other,
but both are present in the narrative.